welcome to this video um yeah you
probably see that it so was on
tournament I intended to play the war
zone final but I messed up the times I'm
simply online at the wrong time that I
don't um managed to play the final so I
joined this war zone phonetics and no i
know i realized i have if all this board
setup wrong how do i fix this
that way
yeah probably okay it's late now i need
to to double also ok so i managed to
enter this this tournament instead
involves very weird way the browser's
acting here i hope this is working ok
Kings gambit we have a midline of them
Knight f3 sister some tricky line for
white why does normally consider them to
be in trouble in this line so on to play
quickly yeah this is two minute chess
I'm more used to five minute really
especially with all the blitz games that
I played recently on icc so of course i
want to get something going here on the
e how should i take only not the shop g6
and g2 were singing so this looks fine
it's only a very slow game I need to
adjust to the side plate haven't played
the this war zone tournaments for for a
long while attacking me for now I'm not
so sure how I will protect us not at all
okay with her move move the mission of
the night then the rookies hanging so I
needed to play this first I could take
and take on only two actually Quinn
takes rook takes it too
yeah now he has a hard time to protect
you too I can just take it like smooth I
think
right come on and here he is the bishop
how to how to do this quickly now let's
try 95 m still blundering this request
night 95 I can take details with the
bishop okay it's an extra rocket is got
11 seconds so don't mind to exchange
looks
yeah rookie to was made of course okay
yeah this was a bit slow this will okay
but I need to adjust to to all of the
sea again and I'm somehow I know the
window size and setup is a bit strange
or very high rated appellant here and of
course a friendly opening hippopotamus
and not in a very very reliable fashion
I mean the hippopotamus is not great
anyway and then brought in this and this
way I don't believe in it at all just
chasing the king
yeah 9595 so spoiled for choice here 95
is good doll your queen e6 yeah maybe
this is a very this is some
non-tournament rating the because this
doesn't really look like 3,000 2300
tournament writing play Bishop 36 is my
by threat now
and of course Queen f7 so it's a bit
much
yeah this is actually easier
yeah not quite sure well just resigns
this is the best move for both of us
because you can play for points instead
of dragging this on
now Quincy service checkmate okay but
quick preemies yeah I want to prevent
castles on yep provoke this weakness
okay
yeah I've already made a tech with a5 a4
yeah sure that 5s coming or you must
play some are getting stuff like my to
h4 or maybe can I teach force not that
bad um night h OS check made up at night
before you can just take okay maybe I
can click we have 5 25 lakhs sir looks
good first link weensy to made to
institute checkmate
I can just take this who i did not take
you fire first this was stupid okay I'm
not in bad shape but still this was was
unnecessary giving away upon don't
really want to exchange Queens yeah it
was saying
yeah I needed this it was important so
how to continue now maybe here we have
to look it to something like this nature
get active yeah I could have taken you
five and then click win at five this
probably a bit if one out right this is
now Turkey 22 looky too yeah i'm i'm
close but for our affairs some guy
okay was a little bit of an accident
here but I get going back it's not not a
big problem
hmm
here Bishop here we'll just just casts
on here yep this is a text b787 probably
needs to go back and now I'm going on
yeah here we take c5 it's it's a
disaster just this wins the house and
what now what's the best move hook th
are probably pinning everything the
night the bishop it's no move
yeah mrs. stalemate have no peace can
move in g6 something still there's no
peace that that is able to move may be
here pushing the porn sale you cannot
play f5 and now I thought we should be
for preventing Knight f6 as well so I
need to go f6 and maybe now back again
so that 97's not possible or is there
something better okay and so came
ok ok I take it
yeah hope t1d something I want to get
rid of this official okay so i'm close
but some guys winning all game six out
of six yeah maybe this reversed grow
three years helping
is defending well III at least okay this
helps
takes Queen Sara so okay that's it said
that I need to exchange Quinn's wanted
to meet quickly and exchanging queenside
doesn't help of course
nope
you need to be quicker disguise other
guys winning all games and to play men
many hit more pre moves here to to speed
up
ok
you're going to cover da Pole I'll go
for a six
come on
ok mate that some other guy has got
seven games played yeah yeah good war
zones hey I'm sorry I just came from
right out of the blue ok some weird get
that line we're just completely
incorrect probably four wide i mean when
i played the set to tend to quickly
it's not greater not great at all I can
take you there wow this is very very bad
night 995 I can take at least look look
here yeah some it's not great but don't
see anything else then to exchange okay
yeah this was crap did i do there he
takes f6 our son was bad okay yeah we'll
need to speed up
oh this is giving me the rook
just just simplifying
you still look up
ok
ok
yeah if people drag on stuff like this I
won't catch up but it would be helpful
to have a quick resins here and there
okay I cannot do much more than when and
try to do this this quickly
ok
this is not great but I don't want to
want to play quickly to have some chance
of catching up Queenie some natural it
has not actually preventing castles oh
he can castle and shoot you right maybe
roop rookie six can irritating
now it probably doesn't it ate him but
it's still not not a great move
yeah this is true rookie 396 and some
bit embarrassing
okay so mm-hmm well knight c6 better I
thought that I might have been some
compensation even with Queens off I
don't pass and exchange Queens no it
does I thought this might be a bit maybe
not enough but his looks are are very
passive
95 a hardy five chick k didn't do it
begin d fine maybe he's seeing it now
nope but i canno counter up here this
was a blunder
roop cheat to win the edge porn it's now
a big problem Wow group g3 yes quite a
move made next move
okay yeah two guys have nine out of nine
and it's only five minutes to go only
way is a super quick win and I'm getting
a 2 1 player oh he actually resigns can
I need some very quick win no matter
what
good take c7 but I needed to take this
risk getting a piece here quickly come
on resins then I really won't have a
chance
but he is also a piece yeah this will
take a while
well this was not the best I want to get
to the king quickly won't resign anyway
probably with the whole set of pieces
down but it will it deliver mate
everything else it's not enough
93 years a threat now okay come on I can
move the king maybe yeah it's not a big
deal but I didn't even calculate this I
was thinking okay this will win anyway
but it's not so clear-cut queen a6 the
skinny phone
you can you form looks with Achilles but
it's not made
okay yeah okay some other guy will win
this thing despite one hundred percent
squawk and now we even exchanged his
Queens creme yeah
okay we'll use some time or whatever it
doesn't matter 11 out of 11 of course
i'm done i've got a rating average of
two hundred higher but this doesn't help
ok
ok
Oh this night is just hanging I
completely forgot that okay come on this
is the way to go for for a quick made me
maybe even if it's completely
nonsensical
yeah kini seven is it is also made
why isn't this a chick made in come on
okay i win the Queen yeah whatever I can
always give made but probably this is
metal yeah right ah what a game so a
night out of nine but there are people
with a much yeah sixth place I don't
know hey I 11 out of 11 you can do it
but not with complete not with non
resign us and relatively strong
opposition I mean it's one hundred
percent what can I do yeah okay up high
am a final was on final on the near
future um not sure next couple of a
couple of days probably yeah I hope you
enjoyed this thanks for watching